c'est un olaf scholz détendu qui se
prête au jeu des selphy à la fin d'un
meeting dans la capitale allemande dans
un sondage publié ce mardi par
l'institut forsa le candidat du parti
social démocrate arrive en tête crédité
de 23% des intentions de vote une
première pour le parti depuis octobre
c'est plaisant de voir comment les
sondages évolué il est touchant de voir
combien de citoyens me font confiance
pour être le prochain chancelier de la
république fédérale d'allemagne
c'est une fonction difficile et quand
tant de gens disent que vous pouvez le
faire c'est un moment très émouvant pour
moi aussi
décrit comme quelqu'un de peu
charismatique au la fiole 63 ans réussit
un plan simple selon l'hebdomadaire der
spiegel être élu en étant celui qui
ressemble le plus à la chancelière
ministre des finances s'est dit
chancelier du gouvernement merkel il a
tiré profit de la pandémie en débloquant
des centaines de milliards d'euros pour
soutenir l'économie du pays
on tâche pour les années 2020 grand h
pour l'avenir de notre pays
un avenir des possibles un avenir
meilleur avec plus de respect de bons
emplois et la protection du climat il
est important que chacun sache que cela
ne peut réussir que s'il ya un
gouvernement dirigé par les
sociaux-démocrates
une campagne électorale jusqu'ici sans
faute al'inverse de ses rivaux qui ont
multiplié les bévues armin laschet tu
candidat de la cd ou héritiers légitimes
de la chancelière s'est effondré dans
les sondages film est hilare pendant une
cérémonie d'hommage aux sinistrés des
crues pris en faute de plagiat dans un
livre il n'est crédité que de 22% des
intentions de vote soit le score du
parti le plus bas enregistré depuis
1984 enfin un temps donné favori au
printemps après la désignation de leur
chef de file anna lena baher boc les
verts sont depuis à la peine une crime
dont des clarisses un soupçon elle aussi
de plagiat dans son livre de campagne et
un cv enjolivé ont discrédité
déstabiliser la jeune candidate de 40
ans entraînant une baisse significative
de son parti dans les intentions de vote
[Applaudissements]